[Music]  mighty words  [Music]  cut okay everyone that was good we can  do 10 better though it's beautiful very  very good  [Applause]  ah my friends from college are here  perfect timing welcome to the set of  chandar dastani Icarus yeah  I'm playing you you like the costume we  need to talk tell the director I have  some notes we need to talk to you in  private oh Karen he's worked with me for  50 years I trust him completely  actually when we first met he thought I  was a vampire and he tried to stake me  through the heart I have apologized so  many times not quite enough times very  close though I'll let you know oh I have  to get ready for the next scene come to  my tent we'll talk there  you guys are gonna love the next scene I  come in on a wire because you know I  can't fly wait are we getting back  together we need to talk the deviants  are back I don't know how many there are  you need to come with us